[Music]
I've mentioned this before one of the
secrets maybe the main secret to a lot
of the wall plain flour stuff is being
able to slightly invert your planes and
I want to talk more about learning
that's the first time by inverting I
mean you can imagine the planes being
flat on a wall plane and you can imagine
them drifting so they're angled away
from you what you want to be able to do
and hopefully you can see this is angle
them towards you just a little bit that
way they fit inside my arms so my right
poised angled a little bit towards this
shoulder this elbow and my left paw is
angled towards this shoulder or this
elbow so the poi fit inside and I can
get my hands really close together and
that makes all of this a lot prettier
because I can keep my hands close so I
can make good buzzsaws it's a really
annoying thing to get it first for a lot
of people and the trick is just drilling
one hand at a time from what I've seen
so that means you pick a direction like
I'm going to have both my pokel and
clockwise I think my right poi and it's
coming up in the middle so I'm going to
slowly bring it towards buzz-saw so it's
coming up my body and make sure you
don't do this
there's no Criss crossing you're just
slightly bending the plane my left boys
going clockwise it's coming down the
middle so as I bend that plane towards a
buzzsaw plane it's coming down my chest
back to wall plane down my chest back to
wall plane and a lot of people default
to this that's that's your muscle memory
wanting you to do something it
understands so that's not what we want
to do here we just bend the
to learn this you might have to spend a
lot of time one plate at I'm going okay
the right boys going clockwise it bends
towards forward buzzsaw left strong
clockwise it bends towards backward bus
right clockwise third one so left
clockwise backward buzz right clockwise
for but and so it'll be until the muscle
memory begins to work and that might be
several days of doing it a little bit
every day another thing helps a lot is I
can start with the right point forward
both saw in the left way backward buzz
saw and that if you find that really
difficult that's the problem that doing
split time opposites is messing with you
so you seem to learn okay right forward
left backward and eventually you can
reverse-engineer it where from here I'm
gonna just let them relax onto a wall
plane and then go back into it and then
they'll relax onto a wall plane and go
back into it now what I've seen when
people go to do that
they revert what at least one of their
point of this again
and that's again muscle memory and it's
not what we're doing right now
we're gonna go from opposites to split
time in the same on wall plane opposites
split time on a wall plane doesn't work
right boy practice back and forth left
boy practice back and forth and if it
doesn't work today
that doesn't mean is anything wrong with
your poi skills it might just mean you
have to come back to it every day one
hand at a time and then at some point it
will click and also making sure you can
start in opposites and eventually you'll
drift to wall plane and then you can go
back and eventually what you do is use
just a little bit invert wall plane a
little bit in vert wall plane or you can
orb you can take them through these full
ranges of motion me where they go you
bend the planes 360 and then you do have
to jump your arms at some point that's a
very cool exercise
so with this one it does I mean I've
seen often people need to persist for a
while but the payoff is good because
once you have control of those planes
you can invert them a little bit a bunch
of moves start getting easier hope that
helps check out my online courses I hope
your PD plants are also coming
[Music]